Tristan Thompson is speaking his truth
after a year full of drama surrounding
his personal life and relationship with
Khloe Kardashian in February 2019 the
NBA Pro allegedly cheated on Khloe with
jordan woods was also accused of dating
Chloe while he was still involved with
the mother of his first child
Jordan Craig and most recently there's
been rumors that he's actually
vacationing with Craig on Wednesday
Tristan took to Twitter to set the
record straight
he claims he spent the last few months
training for the upcoming NBA season and
added that he hasn't been on any
vacations quite simply he called the
current rumors quote 100% false Kristen
went on to defend Chloe tweeting also
when I met Chloe I was single the
negative comments that are constantly
being directed towards her are
unnecessary she does not deserve all
this backlash for my wrongdoings both
Chloe and Jordan have been nothing but
great mothers to my kids Tristan and
Chloe split played out on Keeping Up
with the Kardashians earlier this summer
here's what Chloe told the teen in June
I personally don't watch it back because
I just I already know what happens and
it it's just I think a little too toxic
for me to keep reliving stuff like that
so I stay off social I don't I didn't
watch it and it's just a part of our job
that we kind of have to do so we can't
just pick and choose what we want to
show that's not fair and so that's just
what it is the only thing that really
matters is Chloe and our baby true and
that's it nothing else and all support
should be going for her and how she
feels and that's it
[Applause]